hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger d'abidjan moi j'ai un coup de
gueule avec ma copine en fait elle est
là elle est là c'est quoi son prénom
c'est leslie bien et si bien
[Applaudissements]
jaurès près de cyril moi je respecte
reer et le celi vous le quoi qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
j'ai le cul mais ça valait elle est pris
dans l'engrenage
c'est un coup de gueule mais en fait
c'est plutôt un coup de coeur attendait
alors qu'amy choco qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire on nous a baladés moi je sais pas
moi je les ai vus de faire moi d'accord
ok non
alors depuis le premier jour on s'est
retrouvé donc ça a été le coup de foudre
toi et moi tout de suite elle est tombée
amoureuse de moi avec mes imitations
folle et moi je suis tombé amoureux fou
d'elle parce qu'elle est belle elle fait
rire elle et la joie de vivre et ça que
j'ai pas envie de passer un coup de
gueule
parce que je me suis dit comment ça se
fait n'était pas arrivé avant dans ma
vie ça fait maintenant voilà ça fait un
an qu'on est ensemble
et c'est un an de bonheur et je me suis
dit
david pourquoi tu ne lancerait pas et tu
prouves je n'ai pas tout ce bonheur pour
la vie jusqu'à que jean-michel ne sais
pas
donc là il est en train de la demander
en mariage si la pression c'est un train
de se passer c'est ce qu'est en train de
faire hantagri et la chute attendre
baisse doit douter c'est de la télé
fauqué du riz par mois pour que ça
avance ça non mais c'est quoi l'histoire
ben ouais comme je suis en touche pas à
mon poste en émission préférée de leslie
et moi même je suis dit 'pourquoi
dangereux il ne serait pas un mariage
dans l'émission bah moi je vois qu'un
maire ici c'est jean michel jarre michel
est ce que tu sais faire
[Applaudissements]
venez devant syrie tu fais le témoin de
leslie attendez attendez je vais gérer
je vais gérer ce mariage
alors moi je pense d'abord qu'il
faudrait qu'ils aient une vraie demande
de deux david à l'esprit david je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'il fasse une demande à
genoux à l'esl il faudrait que tu la
demande c'est une vraie demande en
mariage sa surface a eu alors attention
à la jaille ou leslie aujourd'hui 25
avril avec toute l'équipe de touche pas
à mon poste
veux tu m'épouser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
attendez pour l'instant monsieur le
maire monsieur jean michel maire va
célébrer va célébrer ce mariage
attention c'est parti c'est avoue
jean-michel mes bien chers frères mes
bien chers tub en tant que maire de
cette émission nous allons unir en ce
jour na'vi délai slip afin qu'il
devienne marie et eu beau jurer vous de
vous aimer devons chérir gens me aref
jusqu'à ce que les liens sacrés de la
tob n'avais jamais arrêté
si quelqu'un s'oppose à ce mariage
qu'ils parlent maintenant de nagra
jamais david acceptez vous de prendre
pour épouse
leslie je suis présente oui je le veux
leslie acceptez vous de prendre pour
mari le beau david ici présents oui oui
oui oui nous en vertu alors en vertu des
pouvoirs qui me sont conférés par la
tonne
bravo
et le bouquet des rallyes
ouais
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au delà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous d'avoir vous pouvez vous
sentez un dernier truc avant qu'on se
quitte attend toujours
[Musique]